you know it's like this guy that's
[ __ ] the the personality that's just
some white dude and he wants to be
korean have you seen this [ __ ]
or he is korean like what's racist
anymore i don't even know
i don't even know my hands are tied i
don't even know
i don't know what's racist anymore
clue me in dude you can't you can't get
mad at racism anymore because
we don't know what it is you got a
[ __ ] guy who's a white just some
white guy that got 18 surgeries
on his face and now he's like i identify
as korean
kai
is that the most racist thing in the
world
or the least racist thing in the world
because it's one of them
or is it the same most racist
boom less less racist less racist less
racist
less racist so far away less races oops
we thought it was a line as a circle
it's back at the most racist
the guy london guy whatever his [ __ ]
name is
got surgery he says i identify as
non-binary fine
all right whatever i don't that's great
good for you dude
also had 18 surgeries i'm korean now
what
so the left is all outraged at this [ __ ]
i chopped my dick off i'm brave i
slammed my eyes
i'm the worst person we're just changing
my body a little bit what's going on
everybody's mad at the [ __ ] that we said
was okay but now
yeah but you're right okay the left eats
its own man
he's just like but i'm non-binary and
people like but you went too far
[ __ ] y'all dude anybody can be anything
i don't give a [ __ ] that guy is korean
to me
because he wants to be korean he's
korean dude
he's [ __ ] korean
and that's that dude congratulations do
you live in korea or not
because most koreans do so let's have
that conversation
what do i oh well i don't know man i
mean it's got to be crazy growing up
white
yeah i am white wow yeah
it's cool isn't that awesome yeah it's
cool being wet i guess you know it's
whatever i don't really care
i i guess i guess it's nice to be white
sometimes and sometimes it's not nice to
be white wow
that's crazy chris i'm sorry what did
you call me i said that's crazy
chris no no no
i've been thomas jane for five years
i identify as thomas [ __ ] jane
so that's who i am right now i identify
as thomas jane i identify for the coked
out [ __ ]
in the one scene with alfred molina in
boogie nights
that's who i identify as and if you tell
me i'm not thomas jane
i go like this well of course i am
and then the real thomas jane walks in
and he says hey i'm thomas jane and i
say
that's [ __ ] hilarious me too i never
thought we'd meet each other
but i'm you as well
going beyond if someone else identifies
as someone else i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care you want to be korean you
want to be gay you want to be a man a
woman you want to be straight you want
to be white you want to be black
you want to be [ __ ] antonio sabato
junior or mario lopez you want to be
denzel washington
i don't give a [ __ ] even if you're not
denzel washington i don't
care why do we put so much importance
on this why do i have to see this 55
of my life i'm driving down the street i
see billboards it's like
hey this guy is doing this that guy's
doing that i don't give a [ __ ] man do
whatever you want
i don't care i don't always want to be
bombarded with this [ __ ]
people think it's mental illness people
think it's absolutely who they really
are
people think it's not mental illness
fine you know what
i'm no scientist or doctor you have that
discussion
but stop putting in my [ __ ] algorithm
dude
i'm an [ __ ] for this probably
i just don't i just do do what you want
man
that's it i'm thomas jane
and if you tell me i'm not that's not a
hate crime
i just go like this you don't get it bro
i walk out of wherever i am in public
with no shoes on because that's what he
does
didn't you like me in boogie nights you
weren't in boogie nights crystalia
progress
me walking out of the coffee bean and
tea leaf
thomas thomas your coffee's ready hi
do you want to say anything to me like
you loved me in the showtime show hung
that lasted two seasons or hbo whatever
it was i don't remember because back
then i wasn't even thomas jane
[Laughter]
you crystalia don't detonate me
i don't know like whatever dude be mad
cope
my nose is itchy so that [ __ ] rips
my nose is itching it's so good dude
yeah that guy let's look at that video
dude so [ __ ] how mark zuckerberg
[ __ ] was on that high surfboard dude
how [ __ ] egotistical for real is it
to do that kind of surfing
the foil one no i won't touch the sea
i need to be above it dude there's
things in the sea that can literally
murder you in four seconds
no i'll float above it put a fin
but a long [ __ ] phallic fin coming
from under it
listen to this guy doing the [ __ ] and
i do look korean now
about how i identify and i do look
korean now
uh here we go here we go we're starting
at the beginning
hey guys i just want to take this chance
to oh
just [ __ ] has pink hair uh hair all
right also was he just at the gym he's
so sweaty right now and his hair's
astomatted um you know come out today
something that's been like on my mind
for a long time and i've been very
confused about how i identify
i've been very very confused and you
know i've seen a lot of other people
online that have come out
and been very brave about it and shared
their story about how they identify
their gender their pronouns etc so you
know i've taken courage from these
incredibly brave um people and it is
pride also i'm not saying it's not brave
it is brave okay it is totally brave to
come out
as something that people
box you in as all right that is brave
it doesn't mean it matters that much
that's all i'm saying and i'm not
talking about the other come out of the
closet that does matter i get that trans
people get [ __ ] killed
at a high rate i understand that you
know don't [ __ ] pick and choose what
i'm saying and twist it to your
narrative
and be mad at me also it's a comedy
podcast
but let's keep watching the month at the
moment so you know i thought this was
the best time to do it
um you know an ad add a voice add
strength to the lgbtq plus i
community so many letters i'm going to
come out today and say that i've been
transitioning
i've been very unhappy with who i am
deep down um
i want you to be happy because i've you
know i've had like 18 plastic surgeries
now
and i've just had a facelift um brow
lift a temple
lift an eye surgery or canthoplasty
we started making up stuff canthoplasty
made that up dude i
want you to be happy i want everybody to
be happy
i genuinely mean this i want everybody
to be happy
and if this is what makes this person
happy
i want them to do this because what
they're doing
doesn't affect anybody else you want to
change your face
change your [ __ ] face do that you
want to say you're something
say that you make you happy person
um and my teeth done as well um just
these are just part of my transition um
i'm feeling really good i'm for the
first time in my life i feel beautiful
you know i'm looking in the mirror and i
love the way i look good i feel happy
good um and i hope people can respect my
decision it's very
respectful decision to come out this way
um but i am coming out
as non-binary good for you i don't feel
i identify as male or female i just feel
like
i'm just in the middle okay um and
pronouns are they
then korean jimin
jimin what's jimin
oh the guy wants to be somebody that
already exists wow i was doing that as a
bit and this guy is actually doing that
had no [ __ ] idea
okay let's keep going i know a lot of
people died nice to meet you jimin
i'm thomas jane it's not me but i do
identify as korean
and i do look korean now how do you feel
korean i don't identify as british so
please don't um refer to me any media or
anyone online as british because i i
identify as korean that's just my
culture that's my home country
that's exactly how i look now he's
korean um my god david brent dude
and i also identify as jimmy and that's
my career name but uh
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you've followed my journey for the last
eight years i've really struggled with
identity issues
i haven't followed your journey at all
but i'm following it now dude and you're
korean as [ __ ]
i've actually never seen someone more
korean than you let's look at the
[ __ ] things here i never knew you can
identify as a race or culture now
that was posted under the comments as
the top comment by his name is just some
guy without a mustache okay
in some so in disguise has a mustache
for sure a guy with a mustache [ __ ]
his wife
and then he was he was like in youtube
he's like well i'll just be just some
guy without a mustache because obviously
my wife doesn't care um
hi nice to meet you and this is your
husband yeah what's your name husband oh
i'm just calling
i'm just some guy without a mustache
isn't that right honey
i i don't know i i get what you're
getting at no
because uh she seems to be uh
she seems to be taking a liking to men
with
men with my sister at least one certain
guy with mustache
that i saw running out of our place last
night so anyway it's good to be here at
the party
where are the hors d'oeuvres
um
here we go nobody's ever come out as
jimin you know that's what he said
uh this is the whole argument i don't
get looks like society is trying to find
comfortable ways to normalize the
immoral
dude that's not immoral just change your
face who gives you [ __ ]
i love how he was like don't i've done a
farmer's british
i don't want to be cold british if you
see me online and you talk to me
please don't say i'm british
do you understand
there's a little bowler's cap i am not
british good day m'lady
top of the morning to you
oh here comes the ambulance been on and
on
and on
[Music]
that's that good old korean ambulance
[Laughter]
[Music]